14 years of air21 ISM has transformed
turkey from allied to adversary what
does this mean for the United States
NATO is at risk
the defensive alliance is run by
consensus so single objection paralyzes
it there is no mechanism to expel
wayward members even if era Dewan
doesn't seek NATO's destruction turkey
is an intelligence risk integrating
Russian s400 missiles would be in
exposing NATO secrets to the Kremlin
it gets worse in fits of pique air21
exposed to rally spies to Iran and later
leaked the location of American forces
inside Syria to the Islamic state
what comes next to be even worse a
confidant Turkey's intelligence chief
favors Tirana Moscow over Washington
Turkey is currently a partner on the
f-35 Joint Strike Fighter America's
next-generation aircraft should the
Pentagon really trust turkey not to
share the f-35 stealth technology with
Russia Iran and China don't even get me
started on Turkey's terror sponsorship
what to do it's time to stop pretending
turkey as an ally the best policies are
geared to reality not the fantasy of how
things used to be do you think the
United States needs a new strategy
toward turkey let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI